>> BREAKING NEWS ABOUT THE
HORRIFIC MURDER OF A 20-YEAR-OLD
MOM SHOT POINT-BLANK WHILE
PUSHING HER BABY IN A STROLLER.
A LAW ENFORCEMENT SOURCE TELLING
FOX NEWS THAT THE NYPD IS
LOOKING FOR A PERSON OF
INTEREST, THE VICTIM'S
EX-BOYFRIEND IN WHAT'S BELIEVED
TO BE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THE MOTHER CALLED FOR HER
PROTECTION, AND MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
ANNOUNCED THE NATION'S FIRST DNA
GUN CRIMES UNIT.
WATCH HERE.
>> WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE TOO
MANY GUNS ON OUR STREETS.
WE'RE SEEING THE SICKENING
REALITY OF THE OVERPROLIFERATION
OF GUNS AND OBSESSION OF USING
GUNS IN OUR COUNTRY.
AS MAYOR, AS A FORMER POLICE
OFFICER, I'M DEDICATED TO
STOPPING THIS MADNESS.
>> GREG, THIS IS HORRIFIC.
ONCE AGAIN, WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED.
>> YOU KNOW, THE THING IS HE
SHOWS UP AT EVERY TRAGEDY, EVERY
MURDER SCENE, AND I GET IT,
THAT'S WHAT HE'S SUPPOSED TO DO,
AND THEN TELLS YOU THAT IT'S
BAD, RIGHT, THAT IT'S ALWAYS
THIS PROBLEM, BUT IT SAYS TO YOU
THAT POLICE USUALLY DO SHOW UP
AFTER THE CRIME IS ALREADY
COMMITTED, WHICH IS WHY WHEN YOU
CATCH A CRIMINAL, YOU SHOULD BE
KEEPING THEM BEHIND BARS.
THAT'S OUR FIRST MISTAKE.
THE SECOND POINT IS YOU NEED
PREVENTION.
WHAT'S PREVENTION?
YOU NEED COPS ON THE BEAT.
I MEAN, I REMEMBER LIVING IN THE
CITY AND SEEING POLICE ON EVERY
SINGLE STREET.
YOU DON'T SEE THAT ANYMORE.
I FEEL YOU SEE MORE HOMELESS
DRUG ADDICTED ZOMBIES THAN COPS
BY A LONG SHOT.
THIRD AND FINALLY, YOU GOT TO
LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE WHEN THEY
SAY THEY'RE THREATENED.
THEY KNEW WHO THIS GUY WAS.
SHE HAD BEEN ABUSED BY THIS GUY.
YET THE SYSTEM SCREWED HER.
SHE'S DEAD.
THE BABY'S GOT NO MOTHER, NO
FATHER.
>> JUDGE, THE SUSPECT WAS JUST
IDENTIFIED, AND IT WAS GIVEN TO
FOX NEWS, BUT HE'S NOT BEEN
ARRESTED YET.
>> WELL, WHAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS, BESIDES THE TRAGEDY
AND THE HORROR OF IT ALL, YOU'VE
GOT A 3-MONTH-OLD BABY, YOU
KNOW, IN A STROLLER, ON A SUMMER
NIGHT, IN WHAT WAS ONCE THE
SAFEST BIG CITY IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THE MOTHER IS JUST SHOT DEAD
EXECUTION STYLE.
IT'S A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOMICIDE.
IT HAS ALL THE EARMARKS OF IT.
THE MOTHER HAD BEEN BEATEN WHEN
SHE WAS PREGNANT, AND SIX MONTHS
PREGNANT.
OKAY?
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCREASES
IN INTENSITY AND FREQUENCY AS
TIME GOES ON.
SO ANYONE WHO KNOWS THAT WOMAN
KNOWS THAT IF HE'S GOING TO BEAT
HER SIX MONTHS PREGNANT, HE'S
GOING TO REALLY TAKE CARE OF HER
WHEN SHE'S NOT PREGNANT.
SHE CALLED THE POLICE.
SHE WENT TO COURT.
SHE WAS IN A SHELTER FOR BATTER
WOMEN.
SHE DID EVERYTHING SHE WAS
SUPPOSED TO DO AND THE SYSTEM
FAILED HER.
THE POLICE FAILED HER.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE EVER GOT TO
COURT, IF SHE EVER GOT AN ORDER
OF PROTECTION, IF HE WAS EVER
CHARGED WITH A CRIME.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT WHAT I DO KNOW RIGHT NOW IS
IN NEW YORK CITY IT IS OPEN
SEASON.
WE'VE GOT A MAYOR WHO SHOWS UP
AFTER THE CRIME.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I DON'T SEE THE
MAYOR AS A COP.
I SEE HIM AS AN IDEALOGUE,
BECAUSE HE SAYS THERE ARE MORE
GUNS IN OUR CITIES, IT MEANS
MORE LIVES LOST.
FIRST OF ALL, HE'S WRONG ABOUT
THAT.
THERE ARE STUDIES THAT SAY
STATES WITH HIGHER GUN OWNERSHIP
HAVE FEWER GUN MURDERS.
WE'VE ALSO GOT THE CRIME
PREVENTION RESEARCH CENTER SHOWS
THAT CONCEALED HANDGUN HOLDERS
ARE EXTREMELY LAW ABIDING.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, CAN WE HEAR FROM
GOVERNOR HOCHUL?
>> I DON'T NEED NUMBERS.
I HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PEOPLE OF THIS STATE TO HAVE
SENSIBLE GUN SAFETY LAWS.
>> YOU HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PEOPLE OF NEW YORK STATE?
YOUR RESPONSIBILITY THEN IS SIGN
A LAW THAT PUTS CRIMINALS IN
JAIL WHEN THEY COMMIT A CRIME.
STOP WITH THE IDEOLOGICAL
NONSENSE.
THE TRUTH IS WHEN SHE SAYS I
DON'T NEED NUMBERS, SHE DOESN'T
KNOW THE REALITY.
IT'S LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS WITH
GUNS THAT PROTECT THEMSELVES AND
NOT COPS, BECAUSE YOU TIED THEIR
HANDS BEHIND THEIR BACK.
>> JESSICA, THIS IS CAUSING A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO LEAVE LIBERAL
CITIES, NOT JUST NEW YORK, BUT
THE STATISTIC OF PEOPLE LEAVING
NEW YORK IS STARK.
IT WASN'T JUST COVID.
>> NO.
DATA CAME OUT THIS WEEK ABOUT
IT, THE REPORT ABOUT IT, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK STARTED
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE BECAUSE OF
COVID RESTRICTIONS, AND IS
CONTINUING, FOR PEOPLE WHO STUCK
IT OUT, LOOKING AROUND, SAYING,
MY RENT JUST GOT HIKED 25-30%.
IT DOESN'T FEEL SAFE ANYMORE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE BEST
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM, FIGURING OUT
IF THEY WANT TO DO CHARTER
SCHOOLS, PODS, WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE.
I GREW UP HERE.
I WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL ON 89th
AND PARK AVENUE.
THAT'S SIX BLOCKS AWAY FROM
WHERE THIS HAPPENED.
IT'S TRULY FRIGHTENING.
IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING HERE.
IT'S HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
WE HAD THE WOMAN WHO WAS PUSHING
HER BABY AND THE GUY DROVE INTO
THEM AND SHE MANAGED TO -- I
DON'T KNOW HOW SHE PULLED THAT
OFF.
THAT WAS INCREDIBLE.
>> IN LOS ANGELES.
>> IN L.A.
WE NEED REAL POLICY POSITIONS
THAT CAN BECOME ACTIONABLE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF IDEAS
PERCOLATING AROUND.
MAYOR ADAMS HAS PUT THINGS OUT
THERE.
WE NEED TO SEE HOW THEY WORK.
IN TERMS OF THE CONCEAL CARRY
PERMITS, I AGREE WITH HOVER
HOCHUL THAT IN NEW YORK CITY
THERE'S A DISCOMFORT WITH THERE
BEING A LOT OF GUNS AROUND.
SHE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE --
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> NO, IT'S NOT GOOD.
I DON'T WANT TO FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> THAT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE
COMMITTING THESE CRIMES ARE
CRIMINALS.
>> SHE SHOULD HAVE HAD A CONCEAL
CARRY PERMIT.
>> IF SOMEONE IS GOING TO
BURGLARIZE A HOUSE, THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO A HOUSE WHERE THERE'S A
GUN.
IF THEY KNOW THERE'S A GUN
THERE, THEY'RE NOT GOING IN.
>> JESSE WATTERS?
>> WE GET "THE POST" DELIVERED
TO THE APARTMENT EVERY DAY.
THIS IS ON THE FRONT PAGE.
I OPEN IT UP, AND SHE GOES, WHAT
DOES THAT SAY?
LOOKS WHERE THIS HAPPENED.
THIS IS A 20-MINUTE WALK FROM
OUR APARTMENT.
SHE GOES, JESSE, I WANT TO MOVE.
>> YEP.
>> THAT'S JUST HER SPEAKING FROM
THE HEART, BECAUSE THIS WAS -- I
THINK LAST MONTH THREE BLOCKS
FROM MY APARTMENT, THEY HAD A
GUY IN ALL BLACK CHASING THE GUY
ON THE STREET, STABBING HIM.
SO A COUPLE MORE OF THESE, AND
I'M MOVING TO WESTCHESTER,
UPSTATE, NEW JERSEY, GOD HELP
ME, BECAUSE BETWEEN COVID AND
CRIME PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO LIVE
IN THE CITY ANYMORE.
IF I'M WRONG, CORRECT ME, IF
THIS GUY IS BEATING HIS WIFE OR
HIS GIRLFRIEND, HE HAS A
HANDGUN, SHOULDN'T THAT BE RED
FLAGGED AWAY?
>> WE DON'T HAVE RED FLAG LAWS.
>> IN NEW YORK WE DON'T HAVE A
RED FLAG -- I THOUGHT WE HAD A
RED FLAG IN NEW YORK.
>> I GUARANTEE YOU THAT GUN IS
NOT LEGAL.
>> EITHER WAY, IF IT WAS LEGAL,
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN FROM
HIM.
I DON'T LIKE HOW ADAMS TALKS.
WHY ARE YOU READING FROM NOTES?
HE SHOULD BE SPEAKING FROM THE
HEART.
HE SOUNDS LIKE THE PRESS
SECRETARY.
YOU SHOULD BE POURING YOUR HEART
OUT AT PEOPLE INSTEAD OF LOOKING
DOWN, SAYING HOW MUCH YOU CARE,
SAYING HOW BAD GUNS ARE.